We recently put out a video on 10 mistakes
you should avoid when buying a new 2019 MacBook
Pro, and you guys liked it so much that you
asked us to do the same thing for the new
iMac, so here it is.
Here are # Mistakes to avoid when buying a
new 2019 iMac.
For Mistake #1, do NOT buy the cheap $1100
iMac option.
EVER.
No one should buy this model, not even people
on a budget.
You only get a 1080P display, a slow 7th gen
dual-core processor, slower RAM, and integrated
graphics.
It’s basically the worst choice you can
ever make in an iMac.
Paying an extra $200 gets you a much more
capable machine with a much better display.
But even then, I would recommend at least
the $1500 4K iMac because it gets a 6-core
processor and a dedicated graphics card with
4GB of video memory.
If you’re looking to buy a very cheap iMac
for around $1100, you should instead buy a
discounted 2017 model like this one, which
packs a 4K display, quad-core processor and
faster graphics for $450 off.
We’ll link it down below.
For Mistake #2, Do not buy an iMac with either
a hard drive or a fusion drive.
First of all, hard drives are incredibly slow
and they’re more prone to failure compared
to other storage solutions.
Fusion drives combine a large hard drive with
a small SSD, for example, only 24gigs of SSD
for this 1TB fusion drive.
This does speed it up a bit, but it still
has the same reliability issues.
Now an SSD is like a high-speed flash drive,
it has no moving parts so it’s more reliable.
Not only that, but it’s MUCH faster than
any hard drive or fusion drive, and it’s
only a $100 upgrade for most configurations.
We’d recommend getting at least 512GB, but
even the 256gig SSD is a much better choice
than the 1TB fusion drive.
And worst case scenario, you can buy a portable
1TB hard drive for just $45 on Amazon for
long-term storage and backups.
Now onto Mistake #3, if you’re buying a
27-inch model, do not pay for the RAM upgrade.
Keep it at 8GB.
Most people know this already, but this iMac
features a user-accessible RAM door on the
back, allowing you to upgrade the RAM yourself.
It’s incredibly simple and it doesn’t
void your warranty.
We even made a step-by-step guide that you
can follow to do it yourself, and we’ll
put a button on the end of this video that
links to it.
There are four RAM slots, and Apple uses up
two for the factory 8GB of RAM, and yes, you
can add two more sticks and leave Apple’s
RAM in there and it won’t cause any issues.
The 64GB upgrade from Apple costs $1,000,
while you can currently buy 64GB of RAM on
Amazon for only $284, that’s $716 saved,
not including the difference in taxes, and
they’re not any worse than Apple’s RAM.
Trust me, I’ve been using this RAM on my
iMac for the last 2 years.
I’ll leave a link to it down below.
For Mistake #4, some high-end users need a
ton of RAM, like for virtualization or high-end
production work, and they mistakenly by Apple’s
maximum listed 64GB RAM option, but it’s
actually not the max.
The new 2019 5K iMac actually supports up
to 128GB of RAM with OWC’s third-party RAM
kit, and the craziest thing about it is that
it’s only $900, that’s $100 less than
Apple’s 64GB kit.
We’ll also leave the link to that below.
This is huge news for people who really need
that much RAM, allowing them to buy an iMac
instead of going for a more expensive iMac
Pro.
For Mistake #5, the smaller 21.5” 4K iMac
does not have user-accessible RAM.
Some people buy this iMac and buy RAM, then
realize that it doesn’t have a RAM door
on the back.
So don’t make that mistake.
If you need a lot of RAM, the 27-inch 5K iMac
is a much better value.
Let’s say you configure the $1500 4K iMac
option with 32GB of RAM.
That brings the price up to $2100.
Instead, you can upgrade to the $1800 base
5K iMac and buy 32GB of aftermarket RAM for
$142, and you can use that in addition to
Apple’s RAM to make it have 40gigs of RAM,
for a total of $1,942 for a much better machine
with a better display and more performance.
Enough with the RAM, let’s move onto Mistake
#6, if you’re a photographer or someone
who does processor-heavy work, like Logic
Pro or programming, do not upgrade the graphics.
Trust me, you don’t need it.
We ran tests in Lightroom and found that upgrading
graphics did literally nothing at all for
performance.
Instead, put your extra money towards upgrading
the RAM.
We found that having only 16GB limited performance,
so get at least a 16GB Kit and add it to the
factory 8GB for a total of 24gigs if you’re
on a budget, but we’d recommend the 32Gig
kit for a total of 40GB to be safe.
Now onto Mistake #7, if you’re a high-end
video editor, the most important thing for
you is the graphics, and the 2019 5K iMac
has a brand new Vega 48 graphics option, but
you have to choose the highest-end 5K iMac
configuration for the option to show up.
The Vega 48 upgrade is $450, but trust us,
it’s worth it.
Leave the 6-core processor, buy an aftermarket
32gig RAM kit and upgrade to the 512GB SSD
and you’ve got an awesome video editing
machine for just under $3,000.
The reason I say you should leave the 6-core
is because most people won’t see much of
a difference unless they’re high-end RAW
video footage editors.
In that case, the $400 8-core upgrade is worth
it.
And if you can’t afford the Vega 48 option,
avoid I’d still recommend the $2300 5K iMac
because it’s the only other one that comes
with a graphics card that has 8GB of video
memory, and that’s very important for video
editing.
For Mistake #8, don’t pay for any processor
upgrade unless it bumps you up from a 4-core
to a 6-core or a 6-core to an 8-core.
Two years ago, i5 processors did not have
hyperthreading, which gives you two CPU threads
per core, greatly increasing performance,
but now, every new i5 has it, just like i7
processors.
The only real difference is a small speed
boost, which usually isn’t worth the extra
cost.
Now onto Mistake #9, you may have heard that
the 2019 iMac has Intel’s 9th-gen processor,
but be careful because only the top two configurations
can get the 9th gen processor.
The $2300 model comes with a 6-core and the
$1999 can be upgraded to an 8-core 9th gen
for $500.
However, we don’t recommend that you make
that upgrade because if you also upgrade the
storage to 512GB, you’ll end up at the same
exact $2800 price for the same specs as the
upgraded $2300 model, except that you’ll
only get the 570X graphics instead of the
better 580X graphics, so just start with the
top-spec $2300 model instead.
And finally, for mistake #10, don’t feel
like you absolutely have to get the 8-core
to get great performance.
Looking at benchmarks of these new processors,
even the cheapest 3.0GHz 6-core CPU from the
$1800 model outperforms the best processor
available in the 2017 iMac, which I’ve been
using every day for the past 2 years for video
editing and it’s been more than fast enough
for the standard 4K editing that we do.
And there you have it, there are 10 mistakes
you should avoid when purchasing a new 2019
iMac.
You can check out those iMac videos right
there, and If this video helped you out, tap
like and click that circle above to subscribe.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next one!